♪ 哈喽大家好哇 ♪
♪ 灰色的天 ♪
♪ 你的脸爱过也哭过 ♪
♪ 笑过 ♪
♪ 痛过之后只剩再见 ♪
♪ 我的眼泪 ♪
♪ 失了恋 ♪
♪ 失去第一次爱的人竟然是这种感觉 ♪
♪ 总以为爱是全部的心跳 ♪
♪ 失去爱 ♪
♪ 我们就要就要一点点慢慢的死掉 ♪
♪ 当我失去你那一秒 ♪
♪ 心突然就变老 ♪
♪ The day you everywhere ♪
♪ 喧闹的街 ♪
♪ 没发现我的泪被遗忘在街角 ♪
♪ The day you went the way ♪
♪ 有一天也许我能把自己治好 ♪
♪ 再一次想起来应该要怎么想 ♪
♪ 第一次海洋人 ♪
♪ 他的坏 ♪
♪ 他的好 ♪
♪ 却像胸口 ♪
♪ 自己是永远的记号 ♪
♪ 却不见美景 ♪
不光凭自己在
♪ 大家新年快乐 ♪
♪ 让我听到你的声音好吗 ♪
♪ 这个城市已经恋爱占据谁逃得开爱的勇气 ♪
♪ 他大约会吃饭逛街看电影 ♪
都让人变得神采奕奕
♪ 轻轻额头痒痒 ♪
♪ 我左边耳朵朵冰花能让我 ♪
♪ 你不全场张开 ♪
♪ 你的双手跟着我这么做 ♪
大胆的爱
♪ 勇敢的爱 ♪
♪ 刺激又精彩 ♪
全世界幸福在洋溢
没有人需要自我伤心也伤心
♪ 一切新变新街上的情侣最让人如此心惊 ♪
♪ 现在请听口令 ♪
♪ 所有男孩的女孩一备起 ♪
♪ 决定恋爱不幸福 ♪
♪ 绝不放心 ♪
♪ 手心贴手心一切新年新大娃不在意也不满 ♪
♪ 一切同情 ♪
♪ 要有一颗真心去爱另外一颗心 ♪
♪ 现在起心动调皮 ♪
♪ 结局让着你 ♪
♪ 你愿意一起哈哈哈 ♪
♪ honey honey honey在哪里 ♪
♪ 点一首歌最honey甜言蜜语隔空传递 ♪
♪ 加上超多表情 ♪
♪ 感情彼此在心的秘密 ♪
♪ 爱要随身听才是感应 ♪
♪ 多喜欢你 ♪
♪ 这韩语甜言蜜语 ♪
♪ 在我心里爱你的狂蟹日记 ♪
♪ 甜蜜任性 ♪
♪ 充满惊奇 ♪
♪ 永不回你 ♪
♪ 让我关心你 ♪
♪ 用心为 ♪
Hello
♪ 你们好吗 ♪
准备好跟我们一起爱你了没有
♪ Ho baby ♪
♪ 情话多说一点 ♪
♪ 想我就多看一眼 ♪
♪ 表现多一点点 ♪
♪ 让我能真的看见 ♪
♪ Oh bye ♪
♪ 少说一点想陪你 ♪
♪ 不只一天多一点 ♪
♪ 让我心甘情愿 ♪
Hho baby
♪ 情话多说一点 ♪
♪ 想我就多看一眼 ♪
表现多一点点
让我能真的看见
♪ Oh b ♪
♪ 少说一点想陪你 ♪
♪ 不只一天多一点 ♪
♪ 让我心甘情愿爱你 ♪
♪ 多一点才会慢慢发现 ♪
♪ 因为你让我心甘情愿 ♪
♪ 啦啦吧阿吧阿巴BABB ♪
♪ Holy night ♪
♪ Easy ♪
♪ 很easy ♪
笑一笑没什么大不了
♪ 很easy很easy ♪
神奇的爆炸
♪ 就大声唱 ♪
♪ 彩虹是微笑的脸 ♪
♪ 难过就抬起头 ♪
♪ 大声唱 ♪
♪ 爱很easy很easy耶耶耶 ♪
♪ 心情很easy很easy ♪
♪ oh oh oh oh很easy ♪
♪ 很easy ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ 笑一笑没什么大不了 ♪
♪ 天堂是绵绵的糖 ♪
♪ 就算塌下 ♪
♪ 那又怎样 ♪
♪ 雨下再大又怎样 ♪
♪ 该可以开心的淋一场 ♪
♪ 还好不是微笑的脸 ♪
♪ 悲伤打败快乐不需要理由 ♪
海口的朋友们新年快乐